[Music] at the
end of 2010 this liberty saint-exupéry
initiated the construction of a
structuring and ambitious program in the field
of artificial intelligence of
confidence undoubtedly one of the first
in the world
the island project installed from the outset a
transatlantic collaboration between
toulouse and quebec which are two
strongholds of
artificial intelligence and the underlying mathematics
on the other hand aeronautics and
space are two sectors at the forefront
of issues related to systems critical to
their certification
we therefore find  in two
unique places all of the skills
necessary to move this
theme forward and this is what we have
been doing since 2018 certified a system
consists of ensuring a level of trust and
demonstrating this trust to a third party
for many  reasons certified a
system that embeds machine
learning is not possible with
current processes and there are
many issues in paying for the certification  n lies
for example in the ability to specify
the function to be performed or machine
learning obtains its
most remarkable performance precisely in the case
where a knowledge model does
not exist a priori the data becomes
in a certain way specifying for
this reason  and for many others,
we need to invent other approaches
to certification,
we need to implement
mathematical solutions that make it possible
to measure, to guarantee the performance
and robustness of its surroundings and taking
into account  their capacity of course
and in particular the role played by
donors the white paper which produced the
islands project identifies all the
properties that machine learning algorithms should have
for certification purposes
these are the properties that we  export
which we will be implementing
in the confidence project since 2018
and even if there are still two major
challenges to be met, we have done with the
p  project partners several
significant advances in
certification and machine learning in
2021 in we are setting up a
trust project platform in toulouse the team
will be immersed in the
liberty saint-exupéry and friendship teams in order
to implement our tools  and our
skills within kde
varied industrial uses and to amplify the
capacity for technology transfer to
the project partners
[Music]